hey everybody surprise surprise you've
been asking for new DCE you the actor
that played Steppenwolf and justice Li
just did a preview for his character so
I'm going to play this then I'll break
it down the actors name is Ciaran Hinds
because this is only audio we got some
separate visual confirmation of what it
looks like that I'll cut in with it and
surprisingly it's very close to the
Kryptonian ships edges sketch version of
Steppenwolf so here we go it's going to
be quite a busy year for you anyway
because you've got you've got big movie
coming out at the end of the year that
didn't you Justice League uh yeah and we
were talking earlier you're not a comic
book person no not really another person
who's came out of the blue in a way okay
and the fact that you're in it is really
exciting for you oh I'm thrilled to be
here I'm sorry I'm not in costume I
don't even have a costume when I was
doing it so inflamed it's all done what
to call motion capture so basically they
stick a helmet on your head they put two
cameras around and they capture all your
expressions facial expressions so
basically they're going to concoct some
kind of some kind of construction and
they will use my facial expressions eyes
mouth said the performance they will
then return and he'll turn into this
murderous avenging steppenwolf from them
the planet apocalypse
apparently the horse who's bent on hell
on earth yeah haha alright I got have
you seen wonderly he wouldn't have seen
Wonder Woman I don't know what I don't
know whether they're all afraid to come
and meet me I know they weren't really
because I was you know yeah it's
imaginary what you do it with green
screen so you with the other actors are
you having to do you have to the whole
bit bit of a challenge well yeah most
things are a challenge for me Michael
Bradley but that was another challenge
you could say yeah but it was quite fun
and these are very encouraging and what
you do suggesting over here look over
there imagine that do this here they're
coming at you now very I mean as a prin
actor a lovely thing to be able to be
part of our huge franchise like the
Justice League that the superhero movies
then go back into the theatre did is
something that yeah we've I've been very
fortunate that way I don't know why I'm
sure everybody now is recognizing you
for your working going there
yeah I do I wouldn't say get I get
accosted regularly but it's what I've
noticed occasionally word got it yeah
work harder at it the thing that stands
out about that to me is that he said he
was never on set with the other actors
he just had Zack Snyder and the other
people shouting stuff at him like look
over here this is what's happening it's
amazing how movies like this are put
together and if you are new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything and turn alerts on Comic Con
is next week so you don't miss any of
the videos they'll be flash ring
giveaway stuff at the end of the video
too and we can talk about his motivation
the way the films using him is the big
bad instead of going straight to
Darkseid but let's just talk about the
way he looks I think the best comparison
you could make just from a visual
perspective is Ares in Wonder Woman so
just careful for spoilers for Wonder
Woman if you haven't seen it yet we have
to talk about the way they use that
character so at the end of the movie we
find out that David Thewlis his
character is Ares he's a God in an order
of magnitude greater than Wonder Woman
who's also revealed to be part God but
even in his weakened state he's able to
manifest a costume out of a tank he
literally melts the metal of a tank
nearby into a costume that looks
relatively close to his comic book
costume and two swords that he dual
wield so what it sounds like now is that
they were using that movie is sort of a
litmus test for how they did motion
capture for Justice League Steppenwolf
because much bigger movie much bigger
villain much more powerful so you want
it to really pop on screen
so obviously the toy does not do it
justice year but this looks relatively
close to what the Kryptonian ship showed
Lex during Batman V Superman you just
have to remember that the ships version
of edgy sketch can't do color so you
don't see the horns the way they're
meant to appear so because I think there
was a lot of criticism about the way the
Wonder Woman movie treated the Aries
character at the end of the movie I
think they're trying to fix a lot of
that for Justice League because it's a
really cool idea but the third act of
that movie kind of fell apart with the
characters motivations and the way he
looked just wasn't quite as amazing as
you imagined in your head and even the
supposed to version of Ares looked a
little bit different so just given past
experience I would expect Steppenwolf to
look way crazier than you're seeing in
this toy right here but because he's one
Darkseid's elite you have to imagine him
being seven plus feet tall so he's
bigger than Superman also just as
powerful in the grand hierarchy he's
Darkseid's uncle but he's the military
commander so he's the main strategist he
wields a really badass axe but beyond
that the only real powers that he has
are just super strength super durability
on par with Superman and the other new
gods I would say the new gods are a
little more powerful than Superman but
we don't know a whole lot about the new
gods of the DC EU it just sounds like
they're presenting them as being the
relative power levels of the comic book
New Gods compared to Superman of the
other characters so we can do a power
ranking after they drop the Justice
League trailer next week at Comic Con
there will be new Justice League footage
I am 99% sure they're going to drop it
online so I know a lot of you been
asking about the Superman rumor there
been all kinds of evil Superman black
costume crazy stuff going on in the
Internet it's just the way the Internet
is separately people have confirmed that
that's not a thing so I'm not expecting
to see any black costume and I'm also
not expecting to see Superman as a
trailer they've already put them in a
bunch of marketing materials for the
movie so obviously everybody knows that
Superman is going to be in it but I
think they want to hold him back as much
as possible so there's like a 50/50
chance we could see him but you guys can
let me know in the comments do you
actually expect to see Superman in the
next Justice League trailer in whatever
state the movie presents them because
they've been holding back on him all
year and Henry Cavill isn't supposed to
be a Comic Con because he's still
filming Mission Impossible but they
could surprise us and have him show up
but he's got a big mustache right now
because that's way he looks in that
movie so we'll find out next week of
mustache Superman shows up hello do the
sound of this machine gun I am once
again speaking to you using my mind for
those of you asking about the evil
Superman rumors there have been rumors
going around that when he first comes
back he'll be kind of brainwashed
they'll have to fight the Justice League
before he becomes the true Superman of
the DC EU that you always hoped that he
would be now that's also been somewhat
debunked but I haven't heard anything
more about that so I'm not paying too
much attention to it but just a
bring it back around a steppenwolf dark
side in the mother boxes clearly that's
the thing that they're after you even
see one of the para demons manifest in
the trailer right next to where cyborgs
mother box is being kept so clearly
they're trying to get their hands on
them there was a storyline in the comics
it was doomsday annual number one where
the forces of Darkseid go to another
planet and they need to take it because
it has precious materials that they need
for creating weapons so they could be
using a version of that as a reason for
why Darkseid wants earth so bad because
you see these clips of the big blast
back battle clearly he wanted something
they fought him off but he's coming back
to get the mother boxes again it is one
of those big movie things where you
wonder why does everybody keep coming to
earth it was even part of the
Transformers movie not that I want to
reference that but because most movies
have humans in them they take place on
earth you have to explain why it is all
these crazy powerful aliens want earth
so bad they might not use this in the
movie but the way they explain it in the
comics is that earth is sort of a ley
line for magical energy in the source
the source of everyone's power the
source of the New Gods power so it's
sort of like this focal point where you
have a bunch of ants us the humans grow
up on but beyond this there's a lot of
cosmic stuff that's tied to earth did
people humans even Superman doesn't know
anything about yet but I was a little
disappointed that Wonder Woman didn't
explain as much of the mythology of the
DC Universe as I'd hoped
it explained gods and how her powers
work but that's about as far as it went
like there were gods at one point they
all died now there's a demigod
living on earth and that's about it
we'll see how long it takes for those
other gods to be reborn the big Geoff
Johns idea is that when a god dies a new
god is born so I know there's been a lot
of rumors about the Wonder Woman sequel
if you guys want me to do a Wonder Woman
too video just let me know in the
comments we've also got some pictures
from flash episode 2 so that'll be my
next video but if you want Wonder Woman
just let me know in the comments below
congratulations the TJ freegan you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you can click here to learn
about the Batman director talk about
and you can click here for a brand new
Deathstroke arrows even thing
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you